jojo was geht und herzlich willkommen zu
meinem heutigen video wie sich das ganze
an ihr seht wahrscheinlich schon im
titel irgendwas mit aziz und ja ich habe
mir die neuen release gekauft und zwar
hat sich das ganze folgendermaßen
zugetragen ich bin zwar schon länger
interessiert und so und fand auf die
ersten modelle super cool aber ich will
niemals bereit diesen exakten schuh zu
reseller preisen zu holen und ja am
vorabend vor dem gysi release war ich
mit kumpels unterwegs und wir waren halt
unterwegs und haben es so gesagt so ok
morgen release die sie mal schauen wir
jetzt werden sich holen kann oder so als
wäre mal was noch ein bisschen drüber
gemacht und dann war es soweit das der
schule liest ist ich habe dann einfach
die homepage aufgemacht auf meinem handy
und auf meinem laptop nebenbei die serie
weiter geschaut die ich gerade am gucken
war dann merke ich so nach einer kurzen
zeit zur viertelstunde oder so was das
hier auf meinem handy was getan hat und
plötzlich nicht mehr dieser
ladebildschirm da waren sondern ich war
tatsächlich nach viertelstunde durch
gekommen und ich habe es wirklich nur in
ihrem store versucht bei adidas
offiziell und wirklich nur eine
viertelstunde und warum das krass ist
justine zum beispiel hat bei den ganzen
spaß glaube ich fünf stunden oder so
etwas gewartet bei unterschiedlichsten
shops sind
ich habe einfach so unverschämtes glück
also ich bin eigentlich so just for fun
auf die homepage gegangen dachte mir
nichts böses und dann plötzlich bin ich
durch und ich dachte mir so okay jetzt
willst du durch jetzt musst du durch
bei mir hat den schuhen meiner größe
bestellt ich habe ihn jetzt gerade hier
in originalverpackung mit ihm gleich mal
an boxen für euch warum ich den schulbau
bestellt habe ich weiß dass circa so als
wüsstest du morgen steigt der goldpreis
um 400 prozent an willst du jetzt gold
kaufen du überlegst eigentlich über
eigentlich überlegst du gar nicht
sondern kauft den verdammten scheiß
einfach das wäre einfach du mir nicht zu
kaufen ich habe selbst ja einige pass
nico aber ich war noch nie so wirklich
das heißt also ich habe mich schon immer
mit mode beschäftigt und jetzt auch
eigentlich relativ wichtig wie ich
angezogen bin und so aber ein hype ist
war ich noch nie aber jetzt hab ich halt
einfach die seite geöffnet war plötzlich
durch da habe ich mir den schuh gestellt
und sobald ich ihn bestellt hatte erst
mal kurz der beweis dass ich den echten
adidas store gestellt habe also hier
deine bestellung wurde versand bla bla
bla bla
da sieht man ja alle das risiko sbfv die
börse
ich habe sofort als ich die bestellung
abgeschickt habe habe ich sofort gedacht
oh mann es gibt so viele leute wir
aufwarten diesen schuh zu kriegen die
viel mehr hinter ihm her sind als ich
mir habe ich mich so ein bisschen
schlecht gefühlt also gut ich habe
direkt an justine gedacht weil justin
ist für mich so wie sie mensch nur eins
in meinem universum und habe mir direkt
gedacht okay hättest du noch mal
angerufen hätte gesagt was wie eine
größe brauchst du ein herzchen halt für
ihn bestellt aber meinem stellen war
halt schon raus ich werden im moment ein
bisschen überwältigt so und dann habe
ich noch eine stunde oder so was
tatsächlich dagesessen einer serie
weiter geschaut abgewartet ob ich noch
mal durch komme dass sich justin noch
ein paar bestellen kann aber leider hat
es nicht geklappt
ich glaube bei ihm selbst letztendlich
auch nicht aber ja genug zu der
geschichte so habe ich den easy buch
gekauft und packen wir den spaß mal aus
vorab ich habe ja schon gesagt ich bin
kein experte für diesen schuhen also ihr
werdet jetzt keine gigantischen widget
berufs oder so einschätzt sehen bei mir
ich hab eigentlich wirklich nur glück
gehabt ist durchgekommen bin und dann
habe ich so wenig so viel intelligenz
besessen das ritual bestellt habe ich
meine das nicht machen würde ist
eigentlich einfach blöd ob ein schuh mag
oder nicht will ich würde mal sagen
leute letzte rechnung meinem namen usw
und da ist jetzt die berühmte box mit
dem fifty drauf und wir gucken uns das
ganze mal an so retour scheint werde ich
wahrscheinlich nicht brauchen also jesu
postbrief fd made by adidas und hier
sieht man noch größere und so weiter und
sofort drauf und falls jetzt manche
sagen sollten bist du auch sonst so
contra gysi oder sonstwas gewesen ich
habe glaube ich noch nie mich schlecht
gegenüber risiko äußert ich habe mich
nur teilweise öffentlich gewundert dass
leute die reseller preise zahlen
wir eröffnen mal also ich find das
verpackungsdesign ins netz und schauen
wir uns die schuhe man anfangen
ich hab noch nicht gesehen das ist der
schuh okay okay ist
oder meinen kommentar ist in trub so
sieht er aus also die gar nicht mal so
schlecht aus in der hand probiere jetzt
mal auf experte zu machen misst man
schon gefehlt ich wollte jetzt so cool
sein wie bei wie die ganzen anderen
leute und hier zeigen dass er diese
punkte hat aber wie es aussieht sind es
jetzt diese striche da die punkte mit
den strichen die zeigen dass er echt ist
und ansonsten will sich ja auf den
leuten die fakes davon machen viel zu
einfach gestalten
gar nicht gedacht dass ich mal so ein
video mache aber wenn man schon mal ein
paar jesus hat er macht man halt so ein
video oder was meint ihr ich habe einmal
die die jesus von luca getragen hat ja
welche und die fand ich cool bequem also
ich hatte noch nie so noch nie so
bequeme schuhe an die hier werde ich
jetzt auch gleich mal anziehen ich gebe
euch einfach nochmal ein rundumblick auf
den schuh damit diejenigen die ahnung
haben sich überzeugen können dass er
echt ist so leute da seht ihr den schuh
das muster ist eigentlich ziemlich
interessant das hätte ich gar nicht
gesehen so in diesem ganzen aufnahmen
von den produktschutz ist der kleine
orangene pünktchen auch auf der rechten
seite drin hat in dem fall geht das rot
ist extrem krass also wirklich krass
schaaf dann was neu ist ist ja diese
sohle vor allem an dem schuh also wie
gesagt ich bin kein großer experte aber
logischerweise bei den ganzen gysi
videos die so auf youtube waren zum
release des ersten habe ich halt einiges
gesehen und so sieht die unter sole aus
gucken wir uns die dinger gleich mal und
wie kann ich finde so aus der
perspektive sieht eigentlich am
krassesten aus also wenn man dieses
ganze orange ich meine es ist ultra
krass und man kann es man kann aber aus
bestimmten krankes outfit irgendwie
machen wenn man zwischen
die graue hose oder so was hat man
wahrscheinlich wahrscheinlich ziemlich
auffällig und fresh aus aber keine so
alltags mäßig könnte man den pastoren
besten tragen wenn einfach nur so
aussehen würde
nun müssten guckt noch mal rein
altersjahr sie steht da drin ansonsten
müsste es dann noch den gastgebern man
muss schon sagen er hat definitiv was
das sieht richtig flott aus wenn die
dings vorausschauen
die weißen socken ich habe jetzt noch
preisschild abgemacht ist eine option
für mich eine schere geholt klar so
sieht der schule aus er hat schon extrem
tragekomforts ich bin gerade mal ein
bisschen damit rumgelaufen fühlt sich
schon extrem nissan am fuß aber das bin
ich auch von dem schuh von luca die
nicht mal an hatte gewohnt ich dachte
wirklich die story wäre einfach
erzählenswert dass ich ohne weitere
anstrengungen oder sonst was diese
schuhe bekommen habe dir doch sehr
begehrt sind oder waren ich habe schon
einige stimmen gehört die diversion zwei
bluter blabla nicht so gut gefällt wie
die alte aber ich persönlich finde die
schule halt ganz nice aber die mobility
sag ich mal ist halt nicht so ultra hoch
durch diesen orangen streifen und ich
meine du hast das als lisi träger
sowieso schon schwer genug dass du auch
wenn du so ein unscheinbares modell wie
die pedelecs oder
die oxford hendrix wirst du
wahrscheinlich 20.000 mal am tag gefragt
ob du fängst oder echte jesus an hass
und bei den schulen passiert sicher sein
dass ich mindestens noch mal doppelt so
viele leute darauf ansprechen nicht
persönlichkeit denke dann kann ich für
mega an dass mich alle leute deshalb
voll haben aber wie gesagt ich bin mir
noch nicht sicher was mit den schumacher
noch mal einen blick von oben was soll
sie erst mal gewesen sein von dem
heutigen video zeigt euch das irgendwie
interessiert was ich wie ich weiter
verfahren mit den schuhen oder so könnt
ihr mal auf twitter folgen
und wenn ich merke dass ihr da updates
wollt dann gebe ich dir euch dort
ansonsten bin ich mal gespannt wie das
video ankommt ich mein ich hab das
gefühl der hype um den schuh ist
geringer definitiv als bei den ersten
aber der held wird wahrscheinlich
genauso groß sein also ich wie gesagt
ich hab den kauf vor allem getätigt weil
ich einfach nicht komplett dumm bin und
jeder mensch der nicht komplett dumm ist
sollte das machen wenn er die
möglichkeit hat ja das war's von heute
ich hoffe mal das video durchgefallen
und bis zum nächsten mal